[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den richtigen
fragen hierbei bild ja die
bundesregierung in kriegszeiten der
finanzminister bei uns bei bild
christian lindner schon guten tag herr
lindner hallo herr weise ich grüße sie
sind morgen genau drei monate im amt
nachdem sie es lange jahre versucht
haben an die macht zu kommen haben sie
es geschafft fühlt sich das in diesen
tagen aber nicht viel machtloser an den
wie er
angesichts der bilder aus der ukraine
spüren wir alle eine gewisse
hilflosigkeit
weil unsere möglichkeiten begrenzt sind
das was wir aber tun was in unserer
macht steht das unternehmen hier
unternehmen wir ich denke etwa an sehr
wirksame sanktionen gegen das system
putin insbesondere gegen die dortige
zentralbank die solidarität mit der
ukraine
und nicht zuletzt die stärkung unserer
eigenen bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit also ja
wir schauen natürlich auf diesen krieg
und können nicht gleich eingreifen
obwohl wir alle glaube ich diese
betroffenheit spüren aber was geht was
in unserer macht steht das tun wir das
vertiefen wir gleich noch mal wie viel
von ihrem alltag beruflich und privat
ist im moment krieg
die ukraine krise der krieg in der
ukraine
beschäftigt mich im grunde nahezu
vollständig wir sind gegenwärtig auch
dabei den bundeshaushalt für dieses jahr
aufzustellen aber der trägt durch das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
natürlich auch züge der
krisenbewältigung es ist sehr viel auch
vor dem fernseher saugen sie alles auf
am handy alle nachrichten alles was ein
videos bei twitter
soziale medien und fernsehen weniger wie
gesagt ich habe auch entscheidungen zu
treffen und vorzubereiten aber ich habe
einen krisenstab eingerichtet im
bundesministerium der finanzen
der die auswirkungen auf die
kapitalmärkte prüfte da geht es um die
frage der durchsetzung der sanktionen
dass die nicht
umgangen werden können und darüber
bekomme ich auch natürlich die
information was ich politisch und
militärisch tut da bin ich also azzurra
fernsehberichterstattung in meinem fall
jetzt weniger wir sagen natürlich auch
was vor allen dingen unsere reporter aus
dem land berichten was paul ronzheimer
beispielsweise die nachfolge reden hat
ja und er war dort in einem krankenhaus
unten im keller werden dort im moment
die babys versorgt so notdürftig wie das
irgendwie geht das sind kinder die rhein
geboren worden sind in diesen krieg die
ihre ersten lebenstage wir sehen die
bilder von dort unten aus diesem keller
noch mal die die ersten lebenstage
verbringen im krieg und die
möglicherweise auf lange sicht nichts
anderes als krieg kennenlernen werden
können sie mit gutem gewissen kann die
bundesregierung mit gutem gewissen
aktuell sagen dass sie alles getan hat
um diese menschen um diese kinder zu
schützen
wir haben alles getan was
aus unserer sicht möglich war und wir
tun alles was möglich ist und dennoch
hat krieg immer mitleid zu tun und
deshalb bringen wir ja mit den
sanktionen darauf dass das system putin
so nicht weitermachen kann aber alles
getan
alles was in unserer macht stand die
auseinandersetzung und spannung mit
russland hat ja eine geschichte die über
die letzten drei monate die wir im amt
sind sie haben es eben gesagt ja viele
jahre hinaus geht über viele jahre
hinaus geht
aus meiner sicht ist es eine debatte
auch mit wissenschaftlern der einst wert
das zu analysieren weil ich glaube dass
die spannung mit russland
bedauerlicherweise länger andauern wird
aber jetzt im moment spannung oder der
krieg der krieg wir hatten halt wir wir
als europäerinnen und europäer eu und
nato wir haben eine spannung mit
russland krieg wird in der ukraine
geführt
aufgrund des völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffs der der russen auf die ukraine
da wird man dereinst analysieren was ist
genau falsch gelaufen
welcher illusion hat man sich hingegeben
nur momentan geht es ja darum diese
krise zu bewältigen
und da hatte ich die drei schritte schon
genannt der erste schritt die
solidarität mit der ukraine
humanitäre finanzielle auch militärische
unterstützung im sinne der lieferung von
waffen zweiter punkt sanktionen gegen
putin und gegen die russiche kriegskasse
und das dritte stärkung unserer eigenen
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit der
letzte punkt braucht sicher einige jahre
erweise das weiß ich auch 30 bis
2030 nicht 30 jahren aber bis 2030 ist
nicht unrealistisch dass dass der
vorlauf ist also zum ende des jahrzehnts
aber das politische signal das davon
ausgeht darf man nicht unterschätzen
mein kollege der vizekanzler und
wirtschaftsminister der grünen ist ja in
washington dafür gelobt worden hat
anerkennung erfahren dass deutschland
jetzt das schnellste und
umfangreichste programm der stärkung der
verteidigung der aufrüstung kann wird
auch einmal nicht nötig haben und nicht
genau ja ich glaube dass das auch für
einen grünen kollegen eine überraschung
gewesen ist dass er einmal eine
regierung angehört die dafür im ausland
gelobt in der tat wir schauen noch mal
auf bilder aus dem landauer für aktuelle
bilder aus der ukraine das sind bilder
von zerstörung von wohnblöcken nicht
mehr wiederzuerkennen die städte
beispielsweise
charkiw aber auch rund um kiew
mittlerweile solche bilder aus cerny
hilfe aus der stadt beispielsweise auch
zehn kilometer vor cap ihn überall sind
es wohnblöcke in schutt und asche
zerlegt sie werden kaum noch einen
unterschied erkennen zwischen diesen
bildern und zwischen bildern aus aleppo
und grosny werden wieder irgendwann der
vorsitzenden und werden sagen da konnte
man jetzt tatsächlich nicht mehr tun
mehr war nicht drin
also jetzt zur stunde an diesem tag tun
wir das was in unserer macht steht wir
können ja gerne gleich noch weiteres
miteinander
besprechen gerade bei den
wirtschaftssanktionen sehe ich noch luft
nach oben noch möglichkeiten in der tat
wenn es um die
die garten geht die
ihr vermögen dem russischen volk geraubt
haben und die bei uns in den westlichen
demokratien ihren ihren wohlstand
genießen ihre kinder auf privatschulen
geben an der côte d'azur häuser haben
auf dem kurs werden um dann ganz konkret
einfrieren von vermögensgegenständen
unterbinden von zahlungsströmen
einreisebeschränkungen also all das was
der rechtsstaat tun kann sollte er bei
den unterstützern von putin tun es gibt
dazu eine zuschauerfrage die es kann
ganz viele fragen natürlich an sie und
die passt jetzt zu den oligarchen ich
schaue mal gerade die frage lautet warum
man das geld der oligarchen nicht nehmen
könnte um es direkt in die ukraine zu
geben ist das denkbar wenn man die
gelder einfrieren kann dass man das
direkt der ukraine dem aufbau oder gar
zusätzlichen waffenlieferungen das fragt
la dodgers willi aus freiburg ob man das
nicht direkt für die ukraine nutzen
könnte eine tolle idee klingt einfach
ich verstehe absolut das motiv das
hinter der frage steht und mein herz
versteht
was ihr zuschauer meint unser
unterschied zu putin ist aber folgende
wir sind ein demokratischer rechtsstaat
während putin
völkerrechtswidrig die ukraine
angegriffen hat jeden sonntag erinnere
ich daran dass alexej nawalny zu unrecht
als mit der wahrheit in so einem jahr
seit weit über einem jahr genau sie
verfolgen das ja auch hier über die die
bild schon seit sehr langer zeit wir
sind aber ein rechtsstaat das heißt wir
wehren uns gegen putin wir setzen ihn
grenzen der isolieren russland aber mit
den mitteln des rechts und deshalb muss
ich sagen
oligarchen denen können wir reise
beschränkungen auferlegen wir können
ihre vermögenswerte einfrieren dass sie
nicht genutzt werden können sie zu
konfiszieren also einzuziehen für unsere
zwecke geht im rechtsstaat so nicht und
ich bin sehr dafür dass wir gerade in
der auseinandersetzung
mit dem system putin dass wir diesen
unterschied verteidigen wir sind an
demokratischer rechtsstaat bei uns gilt
von der unschuldsvermutung bis zur würde
des einzelnen und dem dem dem verzicht
auf kollektiv haft gilt bei uns die
ganze palette der rechtsstaatlichkeit
und da müssen wir unseren
zivilisatorischen unterschied zu putin
deutlich
lassen sie uns jetzt gemeinsam in die
ukraine gehen zu einem der bürgermeister
die all dieses leid im moment mit
ansehen müssen es passiert
beispielsweise habe ich gerade gesagt in
chief in dieser stadt in der ukraine
dort sind wir mit dem bürgermeister
verbunden mit wladislaw ad rosenke und
in seiner stadt sieht es aktuell herr
lindner unter anderem so aus seit tagen
heftige raketeneinschläge bombardements
bei ihm die menschen wollen nur raus aus
seiner stadt und wir begrüßen ihn
ladislav entree schenke hierbei
bildschirm guten tag herr trozenko
der grünen guten tag können sie uns ein
bild schildern bei mir der
finanzminister deutschlands christian
lindner können sie uns ein bild
schildern wie es aktuell in ihrer stadt
aussieht
maschinist
unserer straße
befindet sich jetzt unter schrecklichen
bombenangriffen von
23 bis 26
august geben 41 1741 das war die
schrecklichste bombenangriffe im laufe
der zweiten weltkrieg unsere stadt war
komplett vom erdboden zerstört
ausgelöscht und heute war hier passiert
russland will
fast so was damals passiert ist noch
einmal
wiederholen und sogar noch mehr
menschen was sie gerade erfahren sind
aggressivste bombenangriff
tagtäglich
werden mit massenhafter über jeder
geworfen tausende wohnungen nutzen der
mehrstöckige häuser werden zerstört
aus also dass möglichen arten
russland
verboten
[Musik]
sie sträuben
nach diesen aggressiven bombardements
die stadt ja nie gewünscht
waren mehr als 40
einfach friedlicher menschen getötet
juni
muss das mal hier heute erfahren
sehr großer kinospaß
sawa sowie einfach reduziert bezeichnen
können genozid der
krise folgen
die stationen befinden uns an der grenze
zu russland und auch
nicht hier wurden auch viele ethnische
russen und auch durchaus
auch meine frau ist eine russin hat
roche enco sie schildern das mit
drastischen worten aussprechen von
genozid dort bei ihnen in der stadt dort
im
nordwesten der ukraine können sie
aktuell sagen wir haben gerade gemeinsam
darüber diskutiert was die
bundesregierung tun kann ob sie alles
tut was möglich ist ob der westen alles
tut haben sie ganz konkreten wunsch im
moment an den westen an europa
ich habe einen ganz einfachen wunsch an
rare europäerinnen und europäer erinnert
euch an das was im laufe der zweiten
weltkrieg geschehen ist glaubt nicht
dass putin stehen bleibt in der ukraine
ist der hitler das 21 jahren dort es
gibt keine garantien die europäer haben
keine
garantieren dass putin in der ukraine
halt macht
deshalb können wir uns an
deutschland
die moderne ausstattung moderne waffen
bereitstellen damit wir über uns selber
schützen können
deutschland soll auch die initiative
ergreifen
zusammen mit anderen nato-staaten den
himmel und der ukraine schlüssen es ist
sehr wichtig
außerdem
sind sehr effektiv und der noch heute
immer noch die europäer russischen gas
und russisches
einmal die antwort des finanzministers
christian lindner wir kennen die
forderungen aus der ukraine die heute
auch genau so der ukrainische präsident
zielinski noch mal formuliert hat unter
anderem flugverbotszone die die nato
sagt dazu ganz klar nein die
bundesregierung sagt ganz klar nein die
bundesregierung sagt aber das haben sie
gerade getan auch noch mal ja zu
weiteren waffenlieferung ihre worte an
herrn entree schenkung ja ich bin
zutiefst berührt wladimir was sie
erdulden müssen welches leid sie sehen
in diesen zeiten kann man zunächst ihnen
einfach nur salutieren für diesen
unbeschreiblichen mut und diese
tapferkeit dass sie
dort für ihr leben für ihr land und ihre
freiheit kämpfen
und ich will ihnen sagen dass wir das
nichtvergessen auch wenn hoffentlich
bald die kriegshandlungen beendet sind
dann werden wir auch danach an ihrer
seite sein was wir tun können
unternehmen wir also die lieferung von
modernen waffen aus europa aus nato
staaten und aus deutschlands läuft ja
nicht alle waffen haben wir selbst als
deutsche jetzt dürfen wir uns nicht
überschätzen wir sind ja gerade selber
dabei wieder unsere verteidigung zu
stärken und wir glauben dass wir am
wirksamsten einen beitrag leisten können
indem wir die russische kriegskasse
trockenlegen das war die zentralbank die
russische wirtschaft ist dabei zu
kollabieren
und hier werden wir unsere anstrengungen
noch vergrößern damit putin einen preis
zahlt und nicht länger durchhalten kann
die wollen dass hier weiter diskutieren
herr trozenko danke ihnen ganz herzlich
und von uns alles gute in ihre stadt zu
ihren bürgern
danke ihnen herr schenkungssteuer können
und für die aufmerksamkeit wie bitte
damit sie verstehen wie sie tragen auch
ein teil der verantwortung für die
verbrechen die russland gerade dabei
geht in der ukraine ohne so in der
ganzen sein scheint heute
russland versucht uns zu zerstören und
ja die besorgnis reicht nicht hälfte
ukraine und ukrainerinnen
danke für ihre worte hat geschenke und
dieser vorwurf der gilt uns allen gilt
nicht ihnen persönlicher lindner der
gilt der bundesregierung aber uns allen
im westen dass wir eben noch nicht ganz
tun was möglich wäre kommen wir konkret
auf dieses embargo zu sprechen dass auch
der bürgermeister dort gerade
angesprochen hat von cerny das ist ja
auch eine forderung die von zellen ski
aktuell kommt warum verzichtet er nicht
sofort auf alles weil das würde sofort
den geldzufluss stören die kriegskasse
leer machen in russland statt dessen
müssen wir uns ja schon den schuh
anziehen dass wir sagen ja im moment
finanzieren wir 200 millionen euro am
tag den putin krieg mit
die kriegskasse also die notenbank ist
ja unter einem schweren embargo das
bedeutet die lieferungen von öl und gas
und kohle nach europa fließt eben nicht
automatisch in seine kriegshandlungen
wir müssten jetzt verantwortlich
entscheiden und deshalb sollte man auch
die
entscheidungsgründe offen legen dann
können sich auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger ihre zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
ein bild machen verzichten wir auf gas
und öl und kohle lieferungen aus
russland
bedeutet das dass die preise in
westeuropa und der welt dramatisch
steigen werden aufgrund der erwartbaren
knappen das wissen alle deutschen ganz
kurz dazwischen wir haben mit hilfe der
bild am sonntag am wochenende ja genau
danach gefragt die mehrheit der
deutschen überwältigende mehrheit sagt
ja sofort stoppen die gaslieferung und
die überwältigende mehrheit der
befragten sagt aber auch nein wir wollen
keine steigende preise akzeptieren und
ich als mitglied der bundesregierung
muss entscheiden weil auf der einen
seite sehe ich die solidarität der
menschen die ich mit der ukraine teile
gestern noch mit der ukrainischen
wirtschaftsministerin getextet der im
persönlichen austausch stehe die mich
anfang februar hier in berlin noch
besucht hat als man sich nicht hat
vorstellen können welche
schockierende und grauenvolle
entwicklung die geschichte hat nehmen
können also auf der einen seite die
solidarität auf der anderen seite die
folgen ich will dass nur kurz noch mal
ausführen damit die menschen sich ein
bild machen können die preise gehen nach
oben und wir können selbst wenn wir das
geld einsetzen
physikalisch nicht einfach kohle und gas
und öl kauft man muss ja physikalisch in
der materiellen realität die rohstoffe
von woanders erst nach deutschland
bekommen dh auf eine mittlere sicht
nicht jetzt nicht im sommer aber
vielleicht im nächsten herbst und winter
hätten der versorgungsengpässe und
müssten sehr einschneidende maßnahmen
diskutieren und deshalb ist meine
einschätzung stand heute
wir sollten unsere eigene
durchhaltefähigkeit nicht einschränken
wie rizzoli russland politisch
wirtschaftlich finanziell und das halten
wir
länger durch als putin unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit aufgrund eben
unserer eingeschränkt rohstoffversorgung
könnte negativ beeinträchtigt werden
wenn wir von uns aus ein embargo
verhängen ich
glaube dass wir hier einfach rational
entscheiden müssen was trifft putin
mittelfristig am stärksten und was
leistet deshalb auch den größten beitrag
sein macht appetit einzuschränken und
ihn in die schranken zu verweisen
das völkerrecht durchsetzt wir haben da
den längeren atem sagen sie nur wir
sehen wie es nach elf tagen krieg in der
ukraine aussieht das heißt das sind nur
elf tage da reden wir über
vergleichsweise kurze zeiträume über
eine million menschen auf der flucht
wahrscheinlich tausende tote
mittlerweile im land das zeigen die
bilder unter
zerstörte völlig dem erdboden
gleichgemacht steht das heißt da läuft
die zeit natürlich ab da hilft ein
längerer atem aktuell an der stelle
nicht können wir da so rational
argumentieren können wir da zwischen
über gaspreise dürfen wir überhaupt über
gaspreise rohölpreise reden oder
überwiegt da einfach die moralische
verpflichtung in diesen stunden in
diesen tagen wenn ein embargo bei gas öl
und kohle etwas an der konkreten
situation heute in der ukraine
verändern würde dann wäre ich für ein
embargo und
das glauben sie aber nicht wenn man
jetzt den gashahn abdrehen würde würde
es keinen moment helfen den menschen in
der ukraine davon sind nicht heute dann
ist die nächste moralische frage und
auch die ist wahnsinnig kompliziert für
uns alle ja zu beantworten die eines
nato eingreifens in diesen krieg der
bürgermeister von journey hat das auch
gerade noch mal formuliert diese
flugverbotszone die ja bedeutet die nato
wäre drin in diesem konflikt wahnsinnig
schwere abwägung wir beziehen uns auf
den nato vertrag der ganz klar sagt die
ukraine ist außerhalb der nato deswegen
müssen dürfen sollen wir nicht in diesem
fall aber können wir so sehr auf dieses
vertragsdetails schauen wenn dort ein
wie er sagt genozid stattfindet nein wir
müssen nicht auf dieses vertrags detail
schauen es ist natürlich möglich auch
außerhalb des territoriums der nato
tätig zu werden wenn alle nato
vertragsstaaten das wollen aber auch da
erlaube ich mir einfach die frage weil
ich bin jetzt mitglied der
bundesregierung
ich habe meinen amtseid geschworen auch
schaden vom deutschen volk abzuwenden
und ich kann nicht kurzfristig nach
meinem eigenen herzens entscheiden
sondern ich muss entscheiden in der
verantwortung für unser land insgesamt
in der verantwortung auch für das was
folgen könnte eine flugverbotszone die
die nato in der ukraine durchsetzen
würde bedeutet in der konsequenz
dass bundeswehr eurofighter mit
deutschen pilotinnen und piloten oder
amerikanische kampfflugzeuge auf
russische flugzeuge schießen
das wollen wir alle nicht und trotzdem
fragen wir uns wie lange wir alle das
ertragen aber bei an ball dann aus der
ukraine aber was folgt daraus wenn ein
deutsches kampfflugzeug auf ein
russisches schießt warum man ein
deutscher eurofighter schießt ein
russisches flugzeug ab was folgt als
nächstes welche eskalation kommt dann
dann bewegen wir uns in einer
eskalationsstufe einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung
auch zwischen russland und der nato auch
zwischen russland und deutschland ist
dass man halt fürchterliches dilemma
dass sie dass das ist ja innerhalb
völlig zu recht ablehnen ausschließen
bis zuletzt dass das was niemand will
dass sie genau das so aussprechen aber
auf der anderen seite jemanden haben der
all das nicht ausschließt sondern genau
damit droht
gerade mir putin muss wissen wenn er
seinerseits
territorium der nato eingreift wenn er
etwa die baltischen staaten bedroht dass
dort wie er als nato-staaten natürlich
reagieren würden und deshalb
trotz aller unberechenbarkeit von putin
weil er um die damit verbundenen
konsequenzen weiß
glaube ich
nicht daran dass wir damit konfrontiert
werden denn die dann folgende
auseinandersetzung
hat potenziell hat potenziell eine
gefahr die die ganze zivilisation
bedrohen ein atomkrieg
bei schwer hat ja bereits davon
gesprochen dass er seine nuklearwaffen
in alarmbereitschaft gesetzt hat oder
zumindest taktischen nuklearwaffen
ich fand es übrigens ausgesprochen weise
und klug dass die vereinigten staaten
von amerika nicht darauf reagiert haben
indem sie ihre nuklearwaffen potenzial
eine höhere alarmstufe versetzt haben
zeichen von stärke das war ein zeichen
von nervenstärke und das nicht eine
eskalation
fortgesetzt werden soll bei der am ende
die es die die konsequenz ein nuklearer
schlagabtausch sein könnte und deshalb
ich will es noch mal sagen es ist keine
keine mangelnde solidarität mit der
ukraine wir tun alles was in unserer
macht steht wirklich und wüsste ich
weiteres außer sanktionen und
humanitärer und militärische
unterstützung im sinne von
waffenlieferungen dann könnte man mit
mir darüber sprechen aber aus diesen
grauenvollen krieg einen noch größeren
krieg zu machen wird nicht leicht
reduzieren sie haben ganz ehrlich
beantwortet und auch mit dem verweis auf
ihren amtseid nämlich dass sie sich eben
natürlich den deutschen volk
verpflichtet fühlen und gleichzeitig
werden wir diese bilder natürlich nicht
los wir werden jeden will jeden tag
wahrscheinlich noch grausamere bilder
ertragen müssen und das leid der ukraine
wird jeden tag grausamer werden gibt es
diesen punkt wo sie eine entscheidung
treffen könnten wie das in den 90er
jahren beim kosovo krieg passiert ist wo
man dann eben sagt das ist eigentlich
außerhalb unserer nato sphäre und doch
sind wir gezwungen etwas zu tun weil
dort eben ein völkermord verliebt wer
das frühere jugoslawien das war ein
bürgerkrieg
wir haben es jetzt zu tun mit einer
nuklear gerüsteten macht wie russland
was haben sie sind familienvater so ist
es
welche abwägung treffen sie und ich
glaube wir haben harte maßnahmen
beschlossen bei den sanktionen die haben
auswirkungen auf uns auf die
energiepreise wir haben eine
jahrzehntelange
politische grundhaltung in deutschland
verändert wir liefern waffen in ein
krisengebiet
aber ich halte es nicht für
verantwortbar dass wir diesen krieg noch
größer machen und daraus eine einer
auseinandersetzung zwischen nato und
russland machen ich sehe übrigens auch
nicht um es klar zu sagen das ist nicht
die meinung von christian lindner hier
ich sehe nicht dass es im kreis der der
nato-verbündeten diese haltung gibt die
gemeinsame position ist wir isolieren
russland politisch wirtschaftlich und
finanziell
wir unterstützen die ukraine mit allem
was wir können aber wir treten nicht ein
in einem krieg mit russland selbst
größten respekt vor ihrer argumentation
auch weil man spürt wie sie das selber
an fast wie sie dieses dilemma umtreibt
aktuell ich will auf eines zu sprechen
zu kommen was man schnell als stammtisch
thema abtun können es kommt unter
anderem von dem us senator lindsay
graham in diesen zeiten der dass bei dem
bei den kollegen von fox news gesagt hat
und dass irgendjemand in russland muss
aufstehen gibt es einen bus in russland
gibt es einen erfolgreicheren graf
stauffenberg in der russischen armee der
einzige weg wie das enden wird ist wenn
irgendjemand diesen kerl verschwinden
lässt sie würden ihrem land einen großen
dienst erweisen sie würden der welt
einen großen dienst erweisen er spricht
damit aus was mancher nur denken mag und
sagt mensch da wäre das problem ja
erledigt am besten den games gar nicht
im moment den wladimir putin haben sie
sich selber bei dem gedanken mal ertappt
und ist so was völlig ausgeschlossen
ich unterstütze die liberale opposition
in russland auch nicht erst seitdem
ukraine krieg sondern auch vorher schon
ich war
kurz vor der pandemie bei meinem letzten
besuch in moskau im gespräch mit
russischen oppositionellen ich sagte
schon jeden sonntag erinnere ich an
alexej nawalny der für seine
überzeugungen und für seinen einsatz für
demokratie und gegen korruption in haft
ist übrigens vor dem ukraine krieg habe
ich nahezu jeden sonntag einen shitstorm
erhalten weil man sagt verfolgt hör
endlich auf damit einer wall nie zu
erinnern und es darf nicht in
vergessenheit geraten habe ich immer
geschrieben und vergessenheit war oft
ein trend am sonntag wo leute sich naja
also nahezu lustig gemacht haben darüber
und über julian assange und andere dann
geschrieben haben ich sage das nicht
weil jetzt irgendeine form von
besserwisserei habe sondern nur um
deutlich zu machen ich will die
opposition in russland stärken und ich
wünsche mir dass das russische volk der
einst auch in in freier selbstbestimmung
über über seinen weg entscheiden kann
ohne diese propaganda gehirnwäsche der
russischen staatsmedien insbesondere
aber ich setze auf den demokratischen
weg jetzt haben wir gerade über
sanktionen schon gesprochen sie haben
auch genau geschildert wo beispielsweise
noch luft nach oben ist bei dem geld bei
dem vermögen der oligarchen der
russischen oligarchen gibt es weiteres
der ukrainische aussenminister hat ja
auch noch mal gefordert dass da
draufgesattelt werden muss gibt es noch
weitere punkte wo sie sagen würden das
könnte auch relativ schnell kommen noch
und ob bei den sanktionen wir arbeiten
auch weiter an einem nächsten
sanktionspaket im kreis der g 7 staaten
rahmen etwa das läuft im grunde 24
stunden am tag sieben tage die woche
also es wird über sanktionen für
institutionen für individuellen
gearbeitet wir haben jetzt gerade in der
letzten woche miteinander besprochen
dass wir auch die bedeutung von crypto
werten stichwort bitcoin uns ansehen
weil man sich so mit hilfe der bitcoins
schmuggelt um die sanktionen sozusagen
anderes zahlungssystem das anna bligh
das thema umgeht dafür haben wir
gegenwärtig also die behörden haben
gegenwärtig dafür noch keine anzeichen
aber wir wollen auch nicht dass das
passieren und insofern der arbeiten
fortwährend daran weiter russland zu
isolieren das ist nicht zu ende sondern
im gegenteil es werden immer neue
maßnahmen gesucht was kann noch getan
werden damit der preis für putin noch
höher wird ich will doch über bilder
sprechen die pforzheimer am bahnhof uns
gezeigt hat von dort gefilmt tat am
bahnhof von kiew massen an menschen die
nur eins wollen raus aus der stadt und
das jeden tag jeden tag dasselbe drama
das sind zehntausende hunderttausende
sie sehen die bilder hier von drinnen
aus der bahnhofshalle und dann die
menschen die sich noch irgendwie rein
drängen wollen in diese züge die
richtung westen fahren richtung lemberg
und den run an die polnische grenze und
ganz viele die auch zumindest an diesem
tag zurück bleiben das wird eine der
wichtigsten fragen in diesen tagen in
diesen wochen sein auch für uns deutsche
das wird eine gewaltige flüchtlingswelle
seien möglicherweise eine wie wir sie
noch nie erlebt haben
da will ich nicht spekulieren wir haben
2015 ja auch enorm hohe zahlen gehabt
aber wir werden unsere humanitären
verantwortung gerecht werden das ist
völlig klar dass bereiten wir ja auch
vor zuständig ist da die innenministerin
aber ich habe in meinem
zuständigkeitsbereich einmal geprüft bin
ja für die bundesimmobilien
verantwortlich wir haben etwa 25.000
plätze jetzt gegenwärtig auch noch frei
für menschen die zu uns kommen können
und wenn menschen aus der ukraine bei
uns schutz suchen dann werden wir uns
natürlich um diese menschen bemühen
ihnen
gesundheitlicher versorgung geben schutz
geben aber meine überzeugung ist auch
dass wir dann sehr schnell
den zugang zu bildung und zu unserem
arbeitsmarkt öffnen sollte natürlich
wird das nicht das erste sein über das
man mit den menschen spricht es sind so
viele kinder jahr wieder ist es hier
wahnsinnig dringen es sind viele kinder
und auch mit den anderen menschen wird
man mit den erwachsenen wird man erst
sprechen müssen über das leid und die
menschen müssen das ja auch die diese
dieses diese diese schockierende
erfahrung überhaupt erst einmal
verarbeiten aber dann wenn das wenn
das soweit ist dass die menschen es
können und wollen dann sollten wir den
zugang zu bildung und arbeit eröffnen
ich glaube von ihrem eigenen hintergrund
und auch den qualifikationen die die
menschen in der ukraine ja selber
genutzt haben ist eine integration in
den deutschen arbeitsmarkt in unser
bildungswesen
sicherlich leichter möglich als etwa vor
einigen jahren nach 2015 live bilder
gerade von der ukrainisch polnischen
grenze auf der polnischen seite viele
von uns am berliner hauptbahnhof gab es
schon tolle szenen da ist man mit
mikrofon rumgelaufen er wurde direkt
zugeteilt am hauptbahnhof da gab es
viele berliner die sofort gesagt haben
ich nehme jemanden von euch von ihnen zu
hause auf ich glaube das sind fragen die
im moment ganz vielen deutschen
haushalten gerade diskutiert werden und
zumindest der gedanke eigentlich müsste
man doch hier kann man ganz konkret
helfen jemanden von diesen flüchtlingen
oft frauen mit kindern aufzunehmen haben
sie einen solchen gedanken gehabt in den
vergangenen tagen
wer hat nicht so ein gefühl das man
selbst aktiv helfen will ich erinnere
mich an ihren ehemaligen chefredakteur
kai diekmann der das 2015 in der
flüchtlingskrise gemacht hat und er oft
dann auch darüber berichtet hat
wir haben in deutschland neben diesem
diesem tätigen mitgefühl und der
solidarität der menschen
gottlob zudem auch noch strukturen
geschaffen um den menschen gerecht zu
werden
eine möglichkeit zu schaffen dass die
menschen auch vielleicht ihre eigenen
vier wände haben
es ist natürlich eine besondere
warmherzigkeit wenn man bei anderen bei
fremden menschen in der wohnung
unterkommen kann aber viele menschen
wollen natürlich auch ihre eigene
privatsphäre behalten sie haben das zu
hause in der ukraine verloren und wollen
jetzt vielleicht hier auch zunächst ihre
eigene familie
situation wieder haben und deshalb ist
für mich das mittel der wahl möglichst
schnell diesen menschen auch wieder den
schutz der eigenen privatsphäre die
zerstört worden ist durch die armee von
wladimir putin wieder herzustellen das
ist ihre allererste aufgabe auch als
finanzminister wir werden gleich über
eine der ganz großen sorgen hier in
deutschland mit blick auf den ukraine
krieg sprechen und der betrifft
natürlich die energieversorgung und vor
allen dingen preise aktuell in zeiten in
denen die preise sowieso so massiv
anziehen darüber sprechen wir gleich
nachher ganz kurzen pause hierbei bild
[Musik]
zurück bei bild mit ihm mit christian
lindner dem bundesfinanzministerium mit
ihm sprechen wir natürlich auch qua amt
über die finanziellen folgen hier in
deutschland dieses ukraine krieges heute
an der tankstelle mit zwei vor dem komma
in weiten teilen deutschlands egal was
man tankt sogar auch beim diesel
teilweise sehen wir hier 2 19 sogar hier
bei diesen tankstellen 214 super also an
die zwei an die gewöhnen bei uns
offenbar an diesem wochenende und können
uns natürlich daran nicht gewöhnen
müssen sie tanken sie aktuell noch oder
hat sich das logischerweise als minister
im grunde erledigt doch ich war auch
noch
autorin immer relativ wenig auto
gefahren gerne aber wenig ich tanke
schon noch insofern kenne ich die
preisentwicklung wir schauen auf die
zuschauerfrage die nahe liegend ist
jentner
mein name ist doch wohl 56 jahre alten
habe eine frage
terminen ja schon gehört und wir sehen
ihn jetzt auch noch
ansonsten machen wir mit ihm weiter mit
frank löser denn diese frage kam 500 mal
klar ob ich frank löser der selber
landesbeamter fdp wähler ist schreibt
dazu er kann sie im grunde das tanken
bald nicht mehr leisten und hat
natürlich eine schnelle lösung menschen
einfach steuern senken großteil des
spritpreises kommt doch vom staat
ja erlöser schreibt dass er 66 kilometer
am tag zur dienststelle pendelt und das
ist genau die arbeitende mitte in
unserem land die gegenwärtig belastet
ist und erlöser was möglich ist tun wir
das gab im grunde noch nie mitten am
laufenden jahr verändern wir ja das
steuerrecht
rückwirkend zum ersten januar wird der
steuerliche grundfreibetrag
um 363 euro erhöht ist eine
steuerentlastung desto mehr drin ich mal
die inflation
gesagt da gleich was zu außerdem die
arbeitnehmer der
arbeitnehmer-pauschbetrag wird erhöht
per fern pendlerpauschale wird erhöht
und die eeg-umlage die noch mal auf den
strompreis drauf kommt wird abgeschafft
nun kommt die die
leider notwendige zusätzliche botschaft
wenn die rohstoffpreise beim import nach
deutschland wachsen dann kann man das
übersetzen damit dass wir alle gemeinsam
ärmer werden wenn unser land insgesamt
mehr zahlen muss für rohstoffimporte zum
beispiel öl dann werden wir als land
insgesamt ärmer das kann der staat
eine zeit
abfedern wir können das sozial
ausbalancieren aber einen
volkswirtschaftlichen wohlstandsverlust
durch inflation insgesamt kann der staat
selbst der deutsche staat nicht auf
dauer ausgleichen okay aber das ist
einmal ganz kurz für uns übersetzt die
wahrheit ihr werdet tragen es gibt
dieses kleine entlastungsprogramm was
aber die inflation jetzt schon nicht
aufhängen und alle nach rechnungen nicht
komplett auffängt und das was jetzt oben
drauf kommt durch den ukraine krieg das
zahlen behindert tankstelle
es zahlt immer irgendjemand der staat
hat ja nur das geld das die bürgerinnen
und bürger ihm zur verfügung stellen das
ist schon klar heißt wir können ja das
ist das ist aber gut dass es der
finanzminister weiß das war vielleicht
in vergangenen halt immer sein um das
nicht immer so das haben sie jetzt
können auch ein klein bisschen über die
kreditaufnahme aus der zukunft in der
notsituation auch noch dämpfen und
abfedern aber wir können eben nicht die
großen wirtschaftlichen entwicklungen
aufheben wir arbeiten nur mit dem geld
der bürger wir verteilen es etwas umwelt
federn ab können kredite aufnehmen aus
der zukunft und deshalb muss unser
hauptaugenmerk darauf legen dass wir
zusätzliche quellen von von energie
lieferungen erhalten dass wir die so
genannten freiheits energien wie ich
immer dazu sage also die erneuerbaren
energieträger in deutschland schnell
ausbauen das kann man tun aber die
folgen der inflation insgesamt abfedern
kann auch der deutsche schnell und
wahrheit profitieren sie ja massiv davon
das wissen auch ein populärer irrtum
naja sie nehmen zumindest höhere
steuereinnahmen einer demo mail eine
leider schauen wir schauen wir ob der
irrtum möglicherweise in ihren reihen
auch vorkommt bei einer ich übertreibe
ein bisschen mitarbeiterin von ihnen von
einer bundesbeamten die uns heute
schreibt im vorfeld dieser sendung das
ist marica schaden müssen sie nicht
kennen sie sagt auch nur dass sie eine
untergeordnete behörde bei ihnen
arbeitet hallo herr linder ich bin als
bundesbeamten für den deutschen staat
tätig und da stehe sogar ihrem ressort
inzwischen kann ich mir kaum noch
leisten mein auto zu tanken um zur
arbeit zu fahren geschweige denn mein
haus zu heizen also was gedenken sie nun
endlich dagegen zu über unternehmen und
da geht es eben auch wieder um die hohen
steuern die der polnische staat
interessanterweise gerade senken also
ich will versuchen die dinge noch ein
klein bisschen zu sortieren zum einen
was gedenken sie endlich zu tun sagt
frau charlene wir kommen ja gerade mit
einem milliardenpaket der entlastung
dass die vorgängerregierung nicht
geplant hat und das vermutlich niemand
dieser bundesregierung zugetraut das
heißt es gibt bereits eine milliarden
entlastung 12 die jetzt steigenden
preise haben auch etwas auch nicht nur
mit der mit dem ukraine krieg zu tun es
sind also auch kriegsfolgen von denen
wir gemeinsam ja gesagt haben wir sind
solidarisch das müssen wir also auch
miteinander
bewältigen wir werden sozial abfedern
wir versuchen zu dämpfen aber es gibt
grenzen denn und dass der dritte gedanke
die vorstellung dass der staat davon
profitiert ist ja nur die eine seite der
medaille
natürlich sind es höhere einnahmen bei
der umsatzsteuer auf energie
aber wenn menschen mehr zahlen müssen
für das benzin und der staat dafür
umsatzsteuer bekommt verzichten die
menschen leider ja auf anderes wofür der
staat dann keine umsatzsteuer bekommt
das heißt wer sein geld ausgeben muss
weil er trump
kauft vielleicht auf der anderen seite
von etwas anderem weniger und unter dem
strich hat der staat eben nicht mehr
geld dafür werden sie für die
argumentation werden die meisten an der
tankstelle verzeihen sie aber ich glaube
relativ wenig verstehe ich dann eben den
ja ich kann den euro nur einmal ausgeben
und ich muss es einfach unterstreichen
der staat kann nur das ausgeben was er
hat ich habe kein eigenes geld sondern
ich verteile das geld der bürgerinnen
und bürger also es gibt keinerlei
überlegungen derzeit die steuern auf
sprit zu senken nein
wo würden sie sagen ist eine grenze
erreicht wir gucken auf die zwei das war
schon immer an die scheuer als minister
hat da gesagt in seinen letzten
amtstagen als verkehrsminister da muss
die spritpreis bremse getreten werden
bei zwei euro jetzt immer darüber gibt
es bei ihnen auch dass sie sagen okay
das ist der kipp punkt ab da ihr kollege
robert habeck hat auch vor
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
verwerfungen gewarnt wenn man jetzt im
zuge von sanktionen massive
preissteigerungen erlebt also gibt es
diesen punkt bei ihnen wo sie sagen okay
dann müssen wir doch helfen ich will
noch mal ihre zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer in erinnerung rufen dass sie
gerade im ersten teil der sendung
gesprochen haben über ein embargo bei
energielieferungen deutschland würden
die preise massiv steigen so ist es ja
und jetzt kommen sie bei der e mails von
ihnen wissen oder denn gibt die
karrieren sage ja nur bei den preisen
die wir jetzt haben sagen sie schon wann
kommt die entlastung und gerade eben im
ersten teil haben wir darüber gesprochen
nehmen wir eigentlich in kauf oder
müssten wir nicht alle in kauf nehmen
dass sie noch höher steigen
was man nicht tun kann ist zu sagen wir
wollen auf der einen seite import
stoppen aber die folgen für alle muss
der staat übernehmen das kann er nicht
wenn ich die möglichkeit hätte wenn ich
eine geldreserve hetze wo ich sagen kann
jetzt kompensieren wir das alles und
niemand merkt würde ich es gerne machen
ich erkenne die sorgen und nöte der
pendlerinnen und pendler ich betreibe
keine politik gegen das auto ich komme
selbst aus dem ländlichen raum und weiß
es gibt menschen die wollen nicht nur
autofahren sondern sie müssen auch jeden
tag autofahren und aus diesem grund
haben wir erreicht dass es anders als
von der vorgängerregierung die übrigens
von der cdu csu geführt war geplant dass
wir jetzt ein entlastungspaket in diesem
jahr bekommen zum ersten ersten des
nächsten jahres wird es weitere
veränderungen geben
regelsatz der grundsicherung beim
steuerliche existenzminimum
beziehungsweise dem grundfreibetrag und
auch beim steuertarif aber jetzt für
dieses jahr haben wir ein paket
geschnürt und nun gilt was ich eben noch
sagte zusätzlich zusätzliche
lieferquellen nach deutschland
erschließen erneuerbare freiheits
energien ausbauen um dadurch die energie
preissteigerung zu reduzieren also ein
sondervermögen spritpreis ist nicht drin
das wäre mit dem grundgesetz nicht
vereinbar ich frage deswegen weil das in
vielen zuschauer zuschriften kam dass
man sagt gar keine kritik daran an der
bundeswehr die muss natürlich stärker
ausgestattet werden völlig richtig aber
da sind mal eben mit einem kniff bei
ihnen wird es ein bisschen schwieriger
sein ministerium dass gerade
herauszufinden wie genau dieser kniff
gehen sollen 100 milliarden knapp aber
es gibt diesen kniff und plötzlich ist
die kohle dafür die bundeswehr für die
man über jahrzehnte kein geld hatte also
könnte durch diesen kniff auch für
autofahrer geben dieser kniff ist kein
trick sondern ist eine notwendige
entscheidung und ich übersetze das noch
einmal wir leihen uns geld aus der
zukunft neben der schuldenbremse um die
lange vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
angesichts der bedrohung unserer äußeren
sicherheit zu beenden und das ist ein
schwerer schritt weil das geld ist nicht
da wir leihen es uns aus der zukunft ich
bin nicht dafür dass wir für die
gegenwärtig gestiegenen spritpreise
jetzt gewissermaßen bei unseren enkeln
ein kredit nehmen das geht nicht das
lässt auch das grundgesetz nicht zu und
ich muss es leider noch einmal sagen
gestiegene preise für rohstoffe kann man
übersetzen mit wir alle werden ärmer das
ganze land wird ärmer wenn wir alle
gemeinsam mehr zahlen müssen für
rohstoffe und das kann der staat nur
abfedern umverteilen aber er kann es
nicht aufheben weil übrigen der staat ja
selber auch mehr zahlt die ja das wollte
ich gerade eben noch ausführen nicht nur
dass für die mehrwertsteuer die wir mehr
einnahmen auf energie mehrwertsteuer aus
anderem fehlt natürlich hat der staat
auch höhere sozialleistungen zu zahlen
die er an die inflation angepasst werden
auch die investitionen des staates
werden teurer das heißt der staat ist
nicht nur profiteur von inflationär wird
auch belastet durch inflation weshalb
wir alles unternehmen müssen um keine
spirale der preisentwicklung zu bekommen
noch einmal ganz kurz auf diese
sondervermögen bundeswehr zwischen zu
kommen dann wird das im gesetz als
gesetzentwurf von ihnen fertig sein dann
werden sie diesen was ich genannt habe
kniff fertig haben
innerhalb der nächsten drei tage wir
haben heute einen vorschlag gehört von
ihrem verkehrsminister gehört und
gelesen in der bild am sonntag der zielt
auf die versorgung der ukraine vor allen
dingen die versorgung der hauptstadt
kiew das wird uns in den nächsten
stunden schon beschäftigen da haben wir
schon am freitag am donnerstag die
leeren regale gesehen dort fängt man in
diesen tagen an zu tauschen was man noch
hat und der notstand wird er sehr
schnell erreicht sein es sollen züge
fahren von deutschland in die ukraine
reihen wie kann das gehen züge in ein
gebiet in dem krieg herrscht wo man gar
nicht weiß wo die leute alle rausdrängen
aktuell haben sie eine idee wie das
funktionieren kann wie die güter
tatsächlich ankommen können wie die züge
geschützt werden können nein das weiß
ich nicht
das ist eine sache der zuständigen
kollegen und auch der sicherheitskräfte
mich hat nur als ich das in den letzten
tagen gehört habe von volker wissing und
anderen hat mir das soll ich sagen
das gezeigt dass da eine hohe
sensibilität da ist dass wir es nicht
bei worten belassen
wenn es um die hilfe die ukraine geht da
sind jetzt sehr ungewöhnliche maßnahmen
auch schwierige maßnahmen will noch mal
an das gespräch mit dem bürgermeister
erinnern als ich sagte dass wir aus
solidarität mit der ukraine unsere
jahrzehnte gültige doktrin bei den
waffenlieferungen verändert haben und
das was jetzt folgt bei der versorgung
der ukraine ist ebenfalls eine
unkonventionelle aber notwendige
maßnahme jetzt gibt sie zeit finde ich
vor dem krieg und seit dem krieg man
kann sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
was in all diesen tagen dramatisches
passiert ist in diesen elf tagen krieg
und für sie mag sich das schon wie eine
ewigkeit anfühlen zu regieren und dabei
sind es gerade mal drei monate noch
keine 100 tage währenden uns nochmal an
dieses zelt das war der auftakt zu den
ampel verhandlungen und dort hatte man
auch verständlicherweise richtig gute
laune mann hat sie gefreut auf das was
da kommt man hat richtig energie gehabt
man hat gedacht man kann dieses land
möglicherweise richtig nach vorne
treiben nichts verlieren wird ja aber
das hat das foto ausgestrahlt energie
und das ist auch etwas was man in den
jahren zuvor ja vermisst hat wenn sie
das mit dem zustand heute vergleichen es
regieren noch schwieriger als gedacht
ich war davon ausgegangen dass wir noch
mit einer pandemie zu tun haben es
zeichneten sich auch wirtschaftliche
schwierigkeiten ab ohne dass man alleine
über die inflation in dieser dramatik
hätte nachdenken müssen das auch noch
ein krieg in europa dazu kommt das war
nicht vorhersehbar
dieses helfe von damals hat trotzdem
noch eine bedeutung
dieses dieses
gemeinsame foto
das war ja nicht ausdruck dass grüne und
fdp jetzt in allem einer meinung sind
erweise das sind wir nicht aber das habe
ich auch gar nicht gesagt allerdings
tatsächlich um den blick nach vorne ich
mag gleichwohl dann ausschließlich
positiv habe der solo sieben leute
damals ja und ich will auch sagen das
ist immer noch positiv ist den
speziellen aspekt hervorheben spd und
grüne auf der einen seite und fdp auf
der anderen seite wir sind nicht alle
meiner meinung wir sind ganz
unterschiedliche parteien diese ampel
war für mich auch keine
wunschkonstellation aber und das hat
dieses elfi ausgedrückt und das gilt bis
heute
es gibt vielleicht gerade weil wir so
unterschiedlich sind das bemühen um
wechselseitiges verstehen und es gibt
eine vertrauliche
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit
und ohne diese vertrauliche
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit wäre eine
solche krisenbewältigung in kriegszeiten
wir jetzt gar nicht möglich und deshalb
also ich bin
froh über die personelle konstellation
die wir haben schwerste entscheidungen
wie man werte von einer ampel koalition
gedacht dass das mal die koalition ist
die die am schnellsten und größten
ausgaben für die aufrüstung der
bundeswehr beschließt man sich weil er
das im indischen seite sind stützt man
sich in diesen momenten wir sehen
annalena baerbock im moment bei ihren
auftritten und schneller als jeder das
erwarten konnte haben die auch eine
ungeheure schwere natürlich bekommen
diese auftritte mit den außenminister
kollegen in europa wir glauben dass auch
bei robert habeck im moment im gesicht
zu sehen und möglicherweise auch bei
ihnen stützt man sich da gegenseitig im
moment auch menschlich ja es gibt ein
sehr enger austausch
und
ein
gemeinsames verständnis um was es hier
gerade geht das ist nichts klein dass
wir haben in einem vorherigen teil des
gesprächs gesprochen über
über eskalationsgefahr
kriegs gefahren für uns die gefahr wenn
man falsch entscheidet dass unser land
großen schaden nimmt ohne dass wir der
ukraine helfen würden und deshalb
ja da sind wir in einer ganz anderen art
noch verbunden und da beziehe ich jetzt
die cdu/csu mit ein die staatstragenden
parteien inklusive der von friedrich
merz geführt
cdu/csu kommen in einer solchen
krisensituation
für europa den gedanken der
menschlichkeit und auch unseren staat
kommen näher zusammen das ein gutes
zeichen man hat das im bundestag ja auch
sehr gut gesehen bei der sondersitzung
ich will jetzt keine parteipolitik
machen aber linkspartei und fdp waren in
dieser in dieser probe für den
zusammenhalt auch in unserem land außen
vor die haben jeweils ihre kleinen
sachen gemacht die afg noch schlimmer
als die linkspartei um das auch klar zu
sagen aber die staatstragenden parteien
standen zusammen und ich habe genau
gesehen dass auch cdu und csu
beispielsweise dem bundeskanzler stehend
applaudiert haben und das macht an am
ende des tages auch die stärke dieses
landes und seiner demokratie und heute
zum ende eben über diese menschliche
seite sprechen und wollte auch auf diese
unbeschwertheit möglicherweise die dass
alfie weitgehende unbeschwertheit die
das helfe jedoch transportiert hat
hinaus die jetzt definitiv
verständlicherweise weg es wir haben
heute bilder aus der ukraine gesehen von
einer hochzeit an der front von lesja
und valerie sie werden selbst haben sie
angekündigt in diesem jahr heiraten gibt
es eine ein paar worte die sie diesem
pärchen von paul ronzheimer heute
gedreht an der front es gibt ein
volkslied dazu die nationalhymne ein
blumenstrauß in den schleier und
uniformen für leicester und valerie mit
auf den weg geben können ja ich wünsche
ihnen frieden und freiheit und zugleich
ist das eine so unglaubliche
botschaft die die beiden an uns wenden
in dieser zeit des krieges an bund für
das leben zu schließen und daraus
spricht ja auch hoffnung auf eine
bessere zukunft und insofern kann man
ihnen nur alles gute wünschen und ihnen
dann für dieses bild der zuversicht dass
sie uns im moment der hoffnung war dass
heute anders und ich danke ihnen schon
dafür spricht für das gespräch gerne an
den finde zu meistern wir sind gleich
zurück bei bild live schneider kurzen
pause danke
[Musik]